she talked trash about Jews now she's
yesterday's news yeah Omar got booted
from the committee and the squad's
reaction it ain't pretty it was the
shrieking heard round the world the
squad is accusing Republicans of white
supremacy because they removed Squad
member Elon Omar from the Foreign
Affairs committee
of course accusing Republicans of white
supremacy is literally all the squad
does all day they should just come to
work in shirts that have that on the
front it would save everyone a lot of
time
check out this from rep Corey bush
Republicans are waging a blatantly
islamophobic and racist attack on
congresswoman Omar and I've said it
before I will say it again the white
supremacy happening is unbelievable I
agree she certainly has said that before
actually I'm not sure that I've ever
heard her say anything else
her private security detail must get so
tired of hearing it
anyway not to be outdone AOC tossed in
sexism like she was cooking a stew on a
gas-powered stove
condemnation of anti-semitic remarks
this is about targeting women of color
in the in the United States of America
don't tell me because I didn't get a
single of time has expired my life was
threatened thank you uh not not really
this is about disciplining a woman of
color for being anti-semitic or are they
somehow immune and wouldn't that be
racist
and how about aoc's Cadence there sounds
like she's auditioning to be a Baptist
preacher
the craziest thing I've ever heard at
least until I heard this
the gentleman's time Omar a gentlemen
this time has expired that our country
is failing you today through this change
the whole country is failing her what
did I do
you know what you did I know but that
was last summer still
see what I did there
I Know What You Did Last Summer yes he's
really mad you had that great joke about
horror movies
but we're not sexist around here we
don't just make fun of crying women
although we could all day we make fun of
crying Man Too
the president likes to say it is never a
good bet to bet against the American
people and he is right
but what I want to say today is it is
never a good bet Tibet against Joe Biden
and this team never ever a good bet
was he doing an impression of Joe Mackey
Ron created those tears the
old-fashioned way by thinking about
Joe's chances in 24.
you know and I'm not even really trying
to say that Elon Omar is all bad I mean
say what you will about her she always
puts her family first
especially when it comes to marrying
them damn that you saw that one coming
right I mean cat I'm not gonna leave
that joke out is this sexism at its
worst
[Laughter]
everyone's like you don't even think
about breathing I'm like speak for
yourself
[Laughter]
no it's not and I really wish people
would I really wish people would stop
calling things sexist when they are not
sexist because it is the best time ever
for actual sexists because you get so
drowned out by everything being called
it that nobody's even listening to
actual examples of sexism which are
absolutely real and still happening and
people compare it to the boy who cried
wolf but it's not because that was just
one boy
that's true yeah and like he got eaten
and that sucks yeah and like thoughts
and prayers to his family but like once
he was eaten that was it it wasn't like
this pervasive issue like it is now and
it like there's never been a better time
to do a sexism because no one will even
pay attention anymore
well speaking of sexism what
yo you know what uh uh I thought
[Laughter]
sorry I was like I was going to think
about what you did last summer and I
just want to get in you know um uh
Tucker made a made a good point it's an
observation that other people have made
that the Democratic party is a party of
weak men and angry women and I started
thinking about that I go I don't think
he's wrong no because I'm trying to
think of like you know you see it's just
like like Cory Booker he starts every
sentence with I'm sorry yeah
uh you know what my favorite part of all
the speeches is they were so
impassionate but they kept having to
read them yeah did anyone notice that
she had to read her apology yeah you
know and
one of the unfortunately as a member of
the minority Community one of the things
that we unfortunately do when we is we
like to include the entire group right
so it's not that I was bad at what I did
or I did horrible things or said
horrible to we it's the group all of us
so if you're going to kick me out you've
kicked all of us out you're racist to
all of us
that's how you know she doesn't have an
argument that's how you know she's she
did what she did because if it was
something that she could combat and
fight with facts and things like that
she would do it but she can't so she
plays this card I'm a woman I'm minority
and you're kicking me out so Adam Schiff
what was his excuse and the little guy
who likes to fart all the time what was
his excuse exactly
what is his name Eric Fartface something
like fartwell fartwell yeah oh that
sounds like honestly if he just came out
with a book that was like called okay I
farted
but he lies about that yeah you trusts
the guy but that's the point they forgot
about the other three white men they got
kicked out so you know it was just a
thing but I loved and the best part was
AOC cannot not talk about herself right
she was supposed to be talking about her
and all of a sudden once she get we got
to work on it's one two three not one
five three you can't not hear you know
you gotta you gotta get a go and that's
why no one did us when I got a death
threat so she made it about her yeah you
know she couldn't even stay on task so
again they had no plan everybody forgot
the script and that was probably my
favorite part and then at the end the
woman told her the gentleman's time is
up so congratulations
running back the gentleman's time is up
had no idea
welcome to the team that is hilarious
Chadwick I mean in a weird way that she
brought it on herself she voted didn't
she kick Marjorie Taylor green off and I
think it was the National Review that
predicted that like you know you know
this is going to come back to haunt you
once you you know once you open that
door the and the what are the horses
that are inside the barn
and then they run out say Pandora's Box
yes the horses are in a Pandora's Box
there you go yes yeah yeah I was just
thinking thank you funny it would have
been if they had the same reaction over
shift or small well yeah AOC from the
pulpit and the Rasheed the blubbering
mess
um but they're doing exactly what uh uh
what the Democrats did to Margie Taylor
green and the Republicans but when they
have it done to them it's literal
violence and
um uh it's uh another thing though I
thought when I was watching this was I
just thought have we reached a point
where absolutely no one is buying this
anymore was anyone watching that and
really believed this this white
supremacy in this racism thing I mean I
can't really imagine even most liberals
were yeah again to like what Kat said
before it's also a great time to be a
white supremacist because the brand is
totally diluted you're in super high
demand yeah these are like through the
roof yeah you know the prisons right I
don't even know what I was saying with I
don't know I feel like white supremacy
went downhill once Larry Elders got in
charge yes right right I don't feel it's
the same brand Kennedy last word to you
do you think there's any kind of defense
for Omar like could you like she I think
third thing is like it's not
anti-semitic to be anti-israel that's
there are that's always their argument
okay but you can question U.S especially
economic involvement in Israel without
being an anti-semite right and there are
a lot of limited government people who
do that who say you know uh anti-war
people like maybe we're sending too much
money and too many weapon systems over
there they don't follow it up with and I
hate Jews yes because that is wrong so
my my problem you're supposed to say I
hate the Jews okay but maybe I'm sure
she has in private yes in public she
said some really bad things and she
never appropriately apologizes for that
she doesn't apologize about you know
hurting an entire group of people who
are targeted for actual violence right
in this country and there are so many
hate crimes against Jews and and they
have only gone up in recent years
because of people like this who will
never apologize and take responsibility
for what they said and try and correct
course you know it's like yes you can do
bad things it doesn't mean that
everybody hates you because you're a
Muslim yeah they hate you because you're
an awful person and you despise an
entire group of people and and through
your actions and statements you sort of
make it okay for other people to hurt
them that's what is so wrong and so
offensive and Rashida Talib everyone's
got someone like this in their family
you know the the shrieking loon that if
you you you're always walking on
eggshells you never want to call them
out on anything because the moment you
say oh did you forget the mayonnaise I
was gonna make potato salads like you
never loved to me yeah
let's go exhausting how dare I in my
family we had two of those people and
they ended up getting married so we
don't even talk to them
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else